i saw you taking photos of your woman
over there did you get the good angle i
always get the good angles very easy
with her no well she actually she hates
last night you were catching some angles
you can't have a bad angle with a woman
like this definitely not yeah it's
awesome you are performing tonight
your special song that is about this
beautiful woman right here what is this
moment going to mean to you
uh it's actually really cool because
it's a lunar eclipse tonight
it's a full moon it's my birthday it's
her birthday tomorrow
i wrote this song two years ago exactly
today wow
played it for it's just it's all a trip
it's like all meant to be do you think
you'll be emotional in the audience
tonight hearing him play twin flame yeah
there's like some really special secret
meanings to the song as well so i'm sure
i will be but i can't cry and
this eyeliner i was gonna say we've got
eyelashes on we can't cry i've got so
many eyelashes i've got like three
strips of eyelashes on each eye no
crying you guys are bringing the fashion
i heard you have 30 000
worth of diamonds on your nails
uh yeah but actually um say that because
now we're gonna well no no so i'm gonna
so so i'm gonna take these off and turn
them into rings and then we're donating
100 of the proceeds to a cleveland
charity and so i'll specify and release
exactly which one and a press release so
with the nails so we see that you know
my my word is bond but yes um can you
give a little flap to the camera yes
these will be taken off my fingers and
turned into nails i mean turned into
rings
and auctioned off and
yeah
proceeds will go to some good i love
that now how are you two celebrating
your birthday tomorrow
we're going away into the desert
together with no cell phones
is this going to be another ayahuasca
experience too but we did that last year
for my birthday so it's not i mean
hopefully it won't be that intense but
it is an eclipse so i'm sure i'll be
crying a lot which is his favorite
i love it now you're heading out on tour
soon with your buddy travis barker
question for you who is making it down
the aisle first you two or court and
travis oh cool i'm not my business
you guys congratulations when the time
does come
have the best day ever we look forward
to seeing everything after i know you
want to be private about it we respect
that so you guys are going to look
amazing and congratulations on your love
[Music]